hello everyone I had an awesome time in
Belgrade meeting David Lada but it's
time to get back to our Bobby Fischer
series this is a round number six
Fischer has the black pieces and he
faces his old rival Samuel Reshevsky now
some of you may know some you may not
know Fisher and Reshevsky have been you
know battling it out for for the past 10
years their match in 1917 1918 was
pretty famous
as it's the first time after Bobby he
was the United States Champion and they
organized a match the prize fund was six
thousand dollars so some of the some of
the stronger grandmasters in the world
like Dignam Petrosyan Benoit bent Larsen
cetera gligar rich all of them for told
that Reshevsky would win this match but
in the end the match was cancelled due
to Bobby Fischer again not not being
cool with the playing schedule there was
this one game where it was supposed to
be played in the afternoon and then they
switched it at 11:00 a.m. and then Bobbi
said he will not play he didn't come for
the game and then the the winner was
awarded a similar reserve ski but even
even before the match got cancelled the
the score was two wins each and seven
draws so it was quite an interesting
match and although we don't have any
photos of this matchup in 1970 in Palma
de Majorca inter-zonal tournament we do
have a couple of photos of their matchup
in 1961 so there you have it
Fisher versus Reshevsky we have quite a
lot of photos of this matchup actually
there they are here one a nice close-up
with a with a huge ashtray on the left
those were the days when you could still
smoke during a chess game and here
another really close up with it with a
slightly smaller ashtray so that being
said let's see how they how they play
now this is 9 9 years after their their
match up in 1961 and although similar
reshef ski is still a very strong player
it Bobby Fischer I mean met and made
made more progress in in these nine
years that den Reshevsky has so let's
see the game Reshevsky opens with d4 we
have Knight to f6 c4 and c5 Fisher drew
the first game then he is now on a
winning streak he won the next four
games and now this is game number six
can he continued the winning streak
let's see for this game
Fischer chooses the Benoni defense and
reshef ski doesn't want to go for the
main main line he doesn't go for d5
grabbing more space rather he goes
Knight to f3 transposing into the
English basically this is the anti
Benoni see capture son d4 Knight
captures and East six Knight to c3 and
Fischer immediately goes for Bishop to
b4 III and now Knight to e4 Fischer
moves the same piece twice in the
opening but he he does so with ideas of
exchanging pieces now what can block
here with the bishop but then Fischer
would really be allowed to exchange a
lot of pieces so instead Queen to c2
which allows officials only exchange one
piece so Fischer plays knife captures on
c3b captors on c3 now attacking the
bishop and Bishop to e7 so what is the
results now from this 94 capturing and
c3 idea Fischer now has a better pawn
structure you can see that White's pawn
structure is a bit ruined but okay in
return the white will get a semi-open
B file and you know the lines of attack
will favor white so both of these
positions are nice it depends on what
you prefer here Bishop to e2 we have
castles by fischer castles by Reshevsky
and now a6
we have f4 official goes for d6 and here
we have f5 a very nice idea by reshef
ski although you could prepare you could
start by ruby one simply keep developing
efore is also an idea to prepare f5 but
Reshevsky doesn't wait he immediately
pushes f5 and although pushing here he 5
does seem like an automatic I mean why
not
Fischer doesn't go for it Fischer
actually captures on e5 e captures on f5
Knight captures on f5 and now Bishop
captures an f5 attacking the Queen Queen
captures on f5 and now Knight to d7
Fischer prepares to bring the other
the other Knight to f6 we have Bishop to
f3 now attacking the b7 pawn now comes
Queen to c7 defending rooftop e1 and
although Fischer can grab the CC pawn
the CC bond will always be a weakness
first you have to protect the B pawn
rook 88 and now comes Bishop to d5
official goes Knight to f6 and now comes
a bishop to a3 and here rook F to e8
okay rook F to e8 does seem kind of
dangerous because the bishop is iron
gave 7 the Queen and rook or both
x-raying f7 if the knight moves but
Fischer's idea is to bring the bishop
over to f8 and then from f8 the bishop
will nicely defend the g7 pawn the d6
pawn and the Queen will still be
guarding f7 so Queen back to d3 because
after the bishop comes to a fade the
rope will be attacking the e3 pawn so
Queen nicely goes back to defend it we
have Knight captures on d5 Fischer on
doubles reshef skis weak C pawn but in
return he gets B 5 B 5 a very nice move
stopping this pawn and c3 now it will
remain a backwards pawn and it will
become a weakness that Reshevsky will
definitely have to think think about we
have E for Bishop to f8 now Fischer will
now prepare his attack on the e4 pawn or
maybe on the seif c3 pawn depending on
what rejewski plays Irish FC plays a
rook to be 4 so he's guarding d4 pawn
but also preparing the advance of his C
pawn so Fisher now transfers his attack
against the e pawn rook to e5 we have c4
and now comes look b to e8 doubling up
on the e-file seek after some b-58
captures on d5 and now came to h1 a very
nice move by Reshevsky
it's very dangerous to keep the King
here on g1 because even if you decide to
give up your epon for this point you
can't really do it effectively because
Queen a7 check in some variations could
pick up the undefended bishop here on a3
so you know you don't want to allow such
things better play King H 1 you know
always well with the position better do
it immediately
Queen to e7 now
creating this Rock Queen rook battery
and e-file Queen captures on b5 rook
captures on e4 rook captures on e4 Queen
captures on e4 and Queen to d7 and this
is the critical moment of the game here
the d6 pawn is under attack by the
bishop from a3 and by the Queen and
refers he probably thought that this is
a move that maybe Fischer will offer a
draw here what he was expecting was rook
to e7 attacking the Queen and after
Queen captures now rook back to e8
attacking the Queen and if the Queen
moves the bishop here and after Queen g3
let's say bushel characters Queen
captures Queen captures here and okay a
Reshevsky will be left with it would
have passed a pawn but most likely I
mean it's it's a pretty drawn endgame
surely he thought you know either I will
win this or or it's gonna be a draw but
Fischer's next move really did come as a
surprise to him he played Queen to f4
and now as you can see you know back
ranked weakness is definitely a thing of
course you cannot capture the Queen
Queen rook captures then rook e1 would
result in checkmate
so you know you can't really afford that
and you do have to do something about
this rook as the Queen is attacking this
rogue the only good defensive move in
this position is actually Queen to b5
you have to bring the Queen back defend
the rook and then Fischer would move his
Queen and the game continues but
fortunately for Fischer and
unfortunately for Samuel Reshevsky
in this position after Queen to f4 chefs
keep late King to g1 he defended the
rook now the Queen has to move also the
f7 pawn is in grave danger you can never
allow Queen captures so what do you do
here unfortunately for chef ski King the
g1 is a terrible blunder that loses the
game immediately what I want to just
tell you how Fischer took advantage of
this blunder I feel free to pause the
video here and find the winning idea so
as usual I will give it a couple of
seconds through to the side for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just continued
your winning streak in 1970 a Palma de
Majorca inter-zonal
tournament and for those who just want
to enjoy the show here Bobby played
Queen to d4 check it doesn't seem like a
terrible
miss by Reshevsky but it actually is of
course you can't go look after rocky one
is checkmate as the rock is now pinned
but the problem is after Queen d4 check
King h1 here
Queen 2 f2 was played by Bobby and it
was in this position that similar reshef
ski resigned the game now why did he
resign well the rook is under attack and
the problem with the previous defense
Queen to b5 this doesn't work because
now you have looked to e 1 and again
White has no moves of course if you
capture Queen captures Queen has to
block this will be checkmate and there's
there's really nothing to do here after
Queen to f2 you could try Queen b5 and
then after rook to e1 try something like
h3 you know make some room for the king
but then you will just get checkmate
checkmate in a different way and there's
there's really no other option here
Queen to f5 would also be an idea maybe
instead of Queen b5
but then black and simply capture it and
if Queen's captured then again rook e1
check will lead to checkmate roadblocks
rook captures and again it's checkmate
but of course Samuel Reshevsky didn't
allow any of this after this Queen to
have to move he resigned the game and
Bobby Fischer continues his winning
streak so after drawing the first game
now the fifth game in a row that he won
and he's really doing excellently in
this tournament so yeah it's very funny
how things happening chess after this
Queen to d7 move he thought okay he has
rocky 7 the game is either either drawn
or you know I'm the one with the outside
passed pawn you know how how does one
lose this but then comes Queen to f4 and
already on the next move you blunder and
lose the game but such is the way of
chess so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it and that you're enjoying
the the coverage of the this series so
far I would like to thank Chris top
smooth man is Ronald Diamond Steve
Ballard Oscar Silva and Mario and Somoza
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon with again from round
seven of the 1970 Palma de Majorca
inter-zonal tournament and as the bill
chess festival is starting soon
I might cover if there will be some
interesting games I will cover
both the Fischer series and the bill
chess festival simultaneously so yeah I
think all and I will see you soon